premier ministre jamais deux sans trois
voilà ce qu'a dit un policier mardi soir
sur la place de la république avant de
s'attaquer pour la troisième fois un
journaliste jamais deux sans trois c'est
ce que semble dire monsieur d'allemands
qui après l'évacuation du pont de sully
en juin 2019 avait demandé un rapport de
monsieur l'allemand qui après la
répression d'une manifestation déjà
place de la république en mars 2020
avait demandé un rapport et ce même
monsieur l'allemand qui a produit un
rapport après les incidents de mardi
le contenu de ce rapport nous ne le
connaissons pas mais il a amené monsieur
d'arman a demandé un autre rapport à
l'igpn celui là nous sommes impatients
de lire tout cela mais au fond le ce
rapport qui nous intéresse celui qu'il
faut changer c'est le rapport de la
police de la république avec ses
citoyens nous ne nous accommodons pas de
la formule du préfet l'allemand nous ne
sommes pas dans le même camp madame
votre gouvernement prétend protéger
policiers et gendarmes
mais c'est lui qui les exposent en
continuant de creuser le fossé
d'alimenter la défiance voulait pousser
à la faute
vous voulez une police qui sert le
pouvoir nous voulons une police de la
république
les violences de la place de la
république constitue le point d'orgue
d'une longue série de dérives
monsieur castet que vous l'avez compris
puisque vous annoncé vouloir saisir le
conseil constitutionnel sur l'article 24
en attendant les rapports allez vous
siffler la fin de la partie
comment surtout comptez-vous recoudre le
lien entre forces de l'ordre et citoyen
quelles consignes allez-vous donner à
monsieur l'allemand pour que la
manifestation prévue samedi à paris ne
donne pas lieu à de nouveaux
débordements
[Musique]